Andy Rydzewski, Cinematographer: David Fincher
going back to Fincher is something he does because
his style of filmmaking freaks me out
a little bit because it's so controlled
Film Courage: How do you decide when to move
the camera and when not to move the camera?
Andy: Yeah moving the camera it's interesting
because and often the director and I will discuss
in pre-production because some directors or
projects want constant movement that maybe
it's like a light float but that is just
always moving in some capacity and then
on other projects or other directors it's like no
only moves when it's a very specific and important
beat i've had shows where we
didn't move the camera period
and i've had shows where it's never still and so
it really just it so depends on the project and
the director really because some of it's
just taste and you know I will have my own
takes on it like if I feel like well moving in
this scene this is such a this this character
is really sad and if the camera's moving around
it's going to feel too sexy or too exciting and
maybe because it's always moving maybe
now it being static is going to accentuate
that because we're used to it moving and vice
versa so context really dictates all of it but
you do want there to be a reason not even
if it's a show where everything's moving
why is it always moving you don't like it's tricky
when when the reason is oh it's just cool like
it's it's not that that's wrong there's no right
or wrong but for me again thoughtfulness is so
important to me like why are things happening
and if the reason is because it's cool like
that's not wrong you know it's just less exciting
it's harder for me to sink my teeth into that and
I think I can get lazy I get you know if it's
just like well there's no I'm just kind of
sliding the camera around then I if I'm not
thinking about what I'm doing you know by by
day three just like what what am I doing here
so so it's it's tricky but you know you want
you want traveling with like something that David
Fincher going back to Fincher is something he does
because he's a his style of filmmaking freaks
me out a little bit because it's so controlled
and I get nervous like would I even be able
to survive a David Fincher shoot I don't know
but his camera tends to lock into actors if actors
are moving the camera's moving and they're in sync
and that's pretty impressive like when somebody's
getting up and sitting down the camera but that
takes you know he does 100 takes of stuff
like it that's hard that's really hard work
but that's an approach that makes sense is
if actor moves camera moves factors still
cameras still but there is just you know
there is everywhere I mean a Michael Bay
thing camera's always alive but that's because
he wants it all to be a rollercoaster ride
and so it's not again it's not wrong it's
just like that's the that's the aesthetic
so I guess it starts from a vision and then
hopefully the camera's movement or lack thereof
at least there's like a string connecting it to
that original vision and again intention did you
see Uncut Gems it did yes that's it yeah Uncut
Gems constantly moving camera which makes that
that character is constantly moving so yeah
that's a perfect example of something that
like there's a reason for that and then it's
just like go go go because it's a whirlwind
his whole life is a whirlwind yeah especially in
the jewelry store or out on the street yeah it
was just constant and and and I think it worked so
well for that film and it was it really conveyed
who he was as a character what his world was like
yeah that's actually a much better example because
I know Michael Bay brings a lot of like people
have a lot of associations but uncut gems is a
great example of constant camera movement for a
reason and very effective it feels very chaotic
yeah that's great what tools or equipment should
a beginning cinematographer buy early because
they're going to be using them all the time that's
a good question I think you know if you can get
a fast lens I think that is a very useful tool a
lens that can you know opens up to at least a two
let's say well i'd say two eight is a good
minimum but if you can get something like these
Rikonons I mentioned those are a 1.5 or something
I think a fast lands is a very valuable tool for a
couple reasons one you can shoot in lower light
situations so it just just helps when you don't
have a lot of gear but also it can teach you about
depth of field because you can get to the extreme
and you can see what a very shallow depth of
field can do for you which but also a deep depth
of field so I think that's one of the I would
probably start there and then beyond that you know
I think it's it's getting easier now but like a
strong light but those are hard to find cheap but
a strong light source i've noticed if you can
have a strong light source coming in a window
it gives you such a great baseline to start
from but usually a bigger light is something
that requires a bigger crew and more money so
that's maybe a little more wishful thinking
there's an app called sun seeker and I think there
are a couple other versions but it can tell you
you know where the sun will be at any time of
day on any day of the year and if you can really
choose those spots I use it for 100 of the spot
unless I'm in a set where there are no windows
I want to know where the sun is going to
be and when and then I'm going to use that
to decide what direction we face and what time of
day we want to shoot there so I think that that's
an indispensable tool as far as I'm concerned
it's kind of expensive but I think it's it's worth
its weight in gold and actually along those lines
there's an app called Artemis which you can put in
any camera and any set of lenses and it will
ingest that and then you can take it you can
be like oh I want to see on an Alexa Mini 50
millimeter from this position that's what this
will look like oh actually no we're shooting a
different camera it's going to be a black magic
it's going to be the 6k pocket cam and we only
have a 40 millimeter you plug it in and same thing
so you can really get a sense of what each lens is
going to show you in a space so I think those are
those are I mean I use both of those tools
constantly on every set i've been on for sure
so I think those are huge um yeah I think
those are those would be the big ones
anything maybe hold off on it's not as
necessary well I you know I think we have
um we all have obsessions with cameras like
camera brands and I think nowadays especially
what you can get with a 1 000 camera blows my
mind and I think you know there are benefits to
cameras like an alexa or red or whatever they
all have they all have their advantages but
not feeling like you have to get a
high-end camera to shoot a high-end image
that is not the case anymore I would say
um one thing if your camera does not have
internal nd filters neutral density filters
one piece of gear that I think you do need are
neutral density filters and they have nowadays
a bunch of different brands of um variable
nds and that's something that you can screw on to
the end of a lens and you can twist it and it will
allow more or less light into your camera
and there are a number of reasons that that's
beneficial but ideally it allows you to start
being conscious about shooting at certain f-stops
it gives you control so like shooting um you know
i've shot shows where we're really opening up and
it's a shallower depth of field a little aimed
more toward beauty and you're shooting at like a
a two or for a lot of it but then there are other
times where I'm like no we're gonna shoot at a
four and it's deeper depth of field and it feels
different but you you don't have that control
unless you have a neutral density filter so that's
something to get but in terms of yes I think
not obsessing about quality of your camera I
think that's something that we all get hung up on
but the the what you can get now is it it just
boggles my mind it's unbelievable so I think
the this the floor has come up so high in terms
of the floor of your image is always going to be
pretty good now in terms of what the camera can
give you at least so yeah not obsessing about
an expensive camera is probably a big thing can
you dispel the myth can you really fix it in post
I hate fixing it in post I am not a believer
in fixing it in post for one it will often
not get fixed in post because just like in
production when you run out of time and money
people run out of time and money and post and
so a lot of things end up just getting tossed
by the wayside um and you know it's important to
know when you can fix something if you're you know
you're on set and you're running out of time and
you're you're the sun is going down it's like well
we're almost out of light but we can still shoot
this but in post they're gonna have to pull it
up it's not gonna look as good but you know the
range it's like we can get it to a certain so
sometimes out of necessity but I i
hate fixing it in post I i think it's
when you start hearing that which you will
hear all the time and I will say it sometimes
but that should never be where
you land if you don't have to
and then when you have to that's the beauty
you can do so much in post these days but
you shouldn't set out with that as your initial
attitude for sure you've been asked to do a
commencement speech at a college what are
your final words to young cinematographers
upcoming generation of filmmakers cinematographers
yeah you know I never would have guessed this
and I i touched on this earlier but coming into
this industry I never would have guessed how far
kindness can get you being pleasant to work with
people are i've gotten I don't know what other
cinematographers do but a lot of them apparently
it's not good because the amount of times
that different departments specifically art
department but and sound and costume that
will come up to me and I'm not I'm not mother
teresa I'm just a normal person the amount of
times that departments come up to me like andy
you're so nice I love working with you it feels
like they've been abused puppies that somebody's
now giving them a biscuit like I'm not so for me
and I same with producers i've had producers tell
me outright that the reason that they rehire me
is because of the atmosphere I create on set
not the visual atmosphere just the vibe and I
never would have thought that that would get me
work that never even occurred to me I'm thankful
that that's true it's it's been good for my career
but I think remembering that this is your life
like the way you spend your day today is your life
and when you're on set if you suck to be around if
you're unpleasant to be around that is not gonna
serve you and what an amazing gift that being nice
and happy can be good for your career like that
that feels too good to be true but that's exactly
what i've found and so I think embracing film
has opened me up as a person got me to be more
confident less shy because I love it so much and
if it's also teaching me to meditate and be kinder
I never yell I never ever yell on set I want to
yell but I don't it's teaching me to like control
my emotions don't blow up be patient that's I i
just it it brings me so much joy to think that
being better at my career makes me a better person
and being a better person makes me better at my
career so I would think that's the best piece
of advice is allow your goodness as a person to
help you be a better craftsman better to work with
everybody wants it I would assume in every field
you said you went on some road trips um after
2009 you know you kind of you know you you
didn't really have that much weighing you down
and what did you see on some of these road trips
yeah I I'm the big there was some quote that
somebody once told me that akira kurosawa said and
then i've tried to find it and i've never found it
so I have no idea somebody just said it to me but
to be a good filmmaker live an
interesting life and I spent
a good chunk of my late 20s and early 30s living a
weird life on the road I was traveling I slept on
couches I slept in cars I slept on the ground
like I was I was adventuring I was I was living
a life and I was um looking at the world around
me like literally just looking at the world
part of that is looking at light but part of
that seeing you know mountains in the snow versus
desert in in the summer versus you know the
seeing an ocean a quiet lake a busy city
these all have a feeling to them and emotion and
having that experience you never know what kind
of script will come your way and what you'll
be able to touch on and then ultimately people
is to to connect with strangers a stranger on a
bus in the middle of Italy or you know wherever
to connect with different people or just watching
people I think that just gives you it gives you a
richer life which then gives you a richer palette
to pull from when you're coming up with ideas so I
really am a big bully now I do wonder sometimes
had I maybe started my career a little earlier
would I be further along now but what I did in my
late 20s early 30s this kind of vagabond life was
interesting and I would imagine it's painted by
experience which I bring to my work for sure so
I think making sure I'm a huge film nerd but
living some life outside of movies I think is a
very valuable thing you know connect with
the world around you as best you can.
Question
For The Viewers: Any other tools a
beginning cinematographer should have?